hey everyone it's Mike from amorphos
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for today's video
I'm going to be talking about the Delta
specifically the max Delta the Min Delta
you know what it means how to use it so
before we jump in if you've been
enjoying these videos don't forget to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell uh so you don't miss a new upload
to my YouTube channel if you find
today's video helpful please be sure to
hit the like button and leave a comment
sharing your biggest takeaway or you
know some of your thoughts on on what
we're talking about today so
let's go ahead and get started with
today's topic now I don't have a
screenshot of the question but it's a
question I get uh uh pretty regularly
asking about Max Delta Min Delta you
know make a video on it sort of
explaining what it is so in the order
flow
you have several Deltas that you're
looking at right you have the Delta
number right which is sort of like the
headline Delta but
you also have two other Deltas sort of
internal readings of the market which is
the max Delta and the Min Delta right
and of course you got cumulative Delta
which is sort of your running Delta
total for the day and Delta into volume
which is you know the the final Delta
number into the bars volume but what I'm
going to be talking about today is the
max Delta and the Min Delta okay so
again every bar is going to have a Delta
Delta is a net difference between
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
in a bar
now what the max Delta is is it tells
you sort of what the strongest reading
on aggressive buying was in a bar so for
example
this green bar right here in the middle
this big green bar it's got a Max Delta
of 390. A Min Delta of minus 47.
now Max Delta can never be negative
mendelta could never be positive because
Max Delta is a reading of the aggressive
buying how strong it was in a bar so
this bar has a max Delta of 390 that
tells me
that at one point in this bar
the the Delta was 390 it was just
telling me there was 390 at that point
in time you know if you sort of take a
snapshot there was 390 more aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers in a bar
and
the mendeltas the opposite in the sense
of negative Delta of aggressive sellers
in a bar so this Bar's got minus 47. so
it's telling me that the strongest that
aggressive sellers were in a bar was
just 47 contracts now
that doesn't mean there was only 47
aggressive sellers in the bar
right this is just how strong they were
at one point now
there's analysis that you can do from it
and you know we've added this into our
order flows Trader software to give you
a quick heads up as to
um you know some of the the interesting
things that is taking place within the
Max and Min Delta so for example what we
do one of our settings is I'll just show
you really quick here pull up the
indicator settings
scroll down in here under it's going to
be under the latter content I believe
here
okay summary content rather
you can see extreme Delta threshold in
percent okay and there's another one
which I'll talk about shortly is a small
min max Delta threshold okay so first
the extreme Delta threshold in percent
is set to 95 so if this bar if a bar
closes within the 95 percentile of the
max Delta or the Min Delta it's going to
color it if it's the max Delta it's
going to color it cyan color which is
like this blue color
if it's going to close if the bar closes
within 95 the 95 percentile of Min Delta
it's going to color it magenta so that's
why you see some Delta numbers are cyan
this light blue and some are this
magenta this sort of reddish purplish
color if it's blue I know that it's
closing near its Max Delta and why is
that important because it's telling me
that there was very strong
buying in a sense in this bar strong
aggressive buying and when the bar
closed it closed sort of right near its
its strongest level in the bar
just as if it was
magenta color right the minus 276 it's
telling me it's closing within 95
percent of the minus 278 which again
tells me there was strong aggressive
selling being carried out in this bar
okay so that's why there's magenta here
and cyan colors okay now the other
setting that I want to talk about
is the
min max is the small min max here so you
can see in here small min max Delta
threshold set to three and the color is
white so I could see in this bar this
bar this bar this Bar's got zero
mendelta this bar here this Bar's got
minus three this Bar's got minus two so
over these three bars
aggressive sellers while there were
people selling into the bid just because
it's zero it doesn't mean that there was
no aggressive selling there was but they
were the aggressive sellers were never
in control of the bar think of a bar
like a tug of war one side is the
aggressive buyers one side is the
aggressive sellers right and you have
the flag in the middle going back and
forth sometimes in a tug of war one side
never gets the flag on their side right
and basically that's what it's it's
telling me but when I see bars
that have a small min max now you could
adjust this right I set it to three so
it's going to be positive three to zero
or zero to negative three for Min Delta
zero to positive three four Max Alpha so
that means zero one two three or zero
minus one minus two minus three
it's just when I start seeing them it's
telling me that yeah you have strong
aggressive buying the aggressive sellers
weren't in control in this bar now it's
one thing to have you know a Delta
threshold number you know being
cyan or magenta and it's one thing for a
bar to have you know a small min max
Delta but you got to know how to use it
right now again if you're not using my
software
say you're just using a normal footprint
chart you know like for example
um
well I don't have one on here but uh
you know there's other softwares out
there that you can get that can show you
the the min max Delta you can just see
it for yourself I like to have things
shown to me highlighted to me that's
saying Mike this is what's happening
right in case I you know you get so
caught up sometimes in analyzing the
market or you're looking at something
else looking at your phone or whatever
you just want to glance up at the screen
and if you see it cyan color or white or
magenta that's your sign right rather
than because you might just miss it
right there's times where
you know we're so busy we just we just
miss something until after the fact and
the bars already started to move away
right from where that interesting order
flow was so what you're going to want to
use these is you know take it in Market
context so for example so what do I got
here this is a one minute e-mini chart
let's go back earlier in the day here to
let's see around
um
here's 824 so 8 30 okay so you know we
opened up for today was non-farm payroll
Friday
um and so there was a lot of movement in
the market but look at this right cash
opens here
not much happening or get within one
tick of the high the high was just made
earlier at 8 24 we get one tick of that
high then you see some strong selling
right now
minus 919 is decent negative Delta minus
400 is decent negative Delta
but sometimes you know that's just kind
of normal negative Delta it's nothing to
get super excited about one way or the
other but then when you pay a little bit
closer attention to the max Delta being
three the max Delta and the next bar
being zero okay yeah you had strong
aggressive you had obviously strong
aggressive selling you got minus 919 in
the Delta minus 400 but at no point in
this tug of war between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers were the
aggressive buyers in control in this bar
it's zero in this bar they just got it
over just a tiny bit three three
contracts more aggressive buying than
aggressive selling and then just went
all aggressive selling from there okay
so maybe that happened you know maybe as
soon as the bar opened but where is it
coming in it's coming in right after we
made a with a one tick run up to the
high
okay now like down here right you see
Zero and three and one right zero three
and here's a seven it's kind of a small
number it's a single digit one and
people say well the market just did this
well you got to take it in context where
do you want to see aggressive selling
come in
you want to see it come in near the high
you want some sort of clue that
aggressive selling is coming in near the
high at you know at 44 area or 42 or
even 40 rather than coming in at 24. 26.
right you're being alerted to it 20
points higher than down here right
that's why I say you know order flow can
help you understand the move as it's
developing
okay
so even though you have the zero the
three the seven the one down here it's
not going to be effective we just had a
20-point sell-off you want to get it as
close to the high of the day or a swing
high if it's small Max Delta if it's
small Min Delta see if there's an
example here small
Min Delta and you got one here it's a
zero okay Mark you know the market
what's it doing it sort of came into a
swing low here popped up a little bit
um
see if there's another small Min Delta
here's some small Max Deltas here right
but again we're at our lows of the day I
want to talk about this in a little bit
and
here's some small Min Deltas right we're
just sort of coming down in here forming
our base and we start reversing going
back up we see small Min Deltas zero one
zero zero zero I said one zero and a
zero here
okay so that's you know how you're going
to want to use the min max Delta if
you're looking at the min max Delta
honestly if you're just using a regular
footprint chart and you have min max
Delta on there put it on there start
observing these things seeing how the
market is you know reacting around swing
highs or swing lows highs of days those
are the days now
getting onto the
Delta thresholds right the my the cyan
color these blue colors right and these
magenta colors again same concept if
you're seeing
if what you want to see around lows of
the day or swing lows
is some sort of buying coming in right
you want to see positive Delta obviously
but if that Delta is closing near its
Max Delta it's telling you it's quite
strong right aggressive buyers have
taken over the bar
and being consistent until the bar
closes so for example here right 1050
it's closing right on its Max Delta here
it's 109 it closed at 109. okay but this
one's quite strong then you see the zero
zero coming afterwards right here as the
market is selling off
okay yeah I'm fine with the negative
Delta closing near its negative Delta
it's it's Min Delta number right 674
closing
nearest minus 697 minus 863
versus minus 888 the Market's selling
off that's what I like to see on a
strong sell-off but if it looks to me
like this Market is bottoming out and it
and it kind of is here you could just
see it going sideways then you're
starting to see signs in the Delta
picking up that's your cue to take those
trades just as
you know here right we get we just make
a new low right here okay you got a nice
strong Delta here three three eights
closing near 355. okay just sort of went
sideways
some more selling coming in now look at
these bars right zero zero zero zero it
was like oh my God it's it's got four
zeros in a row that must be super strong
well you're low of the day you just made
your low right here
and this is where you know it helps to
understand
the order flow because people will just
look at this
you know I get
I don't want to say it but you know
people will see this zero zero zero
expect the market to sell off the market
doesn't sell off uh order flow is is
garbage there's no point in using order
flow because it's all zero zeros a
strong aggressive selling in the market
didn't sell off well
why
it's not because order flow is garbage
order flow is telling you something
strong aggressive sellers but it's
probably being absorbed as this Market
is sort of going sideways that's what
that means when you've got strong
aggressive selling it's the people that
will comment like that that just don't
understand the market they don't
understand how absorption works when you
have strong selling and it can't move
the market it's being absorbed that is
the definition of absorption
and then you start seeing the aggressive
buying coming in so you got strong
selling
being met with absorption
the aggressive buying coming in here
521 closing near 544 1150 closing near
1161. I mean it doesn't get any more
clearer than that but sometimes you know
people will stop at this art and say
Well they're strong selling the market
should have sold off it didn't see order
flow is garbage it doesn't matter
blah blah blah okay fine
take that thought go away trade your way
there's enough people I know that trade
overflow and see something like this and
understand it and profit from it because
they understand what absorption is what
what it looks like in the market and
they can take advantage of it
Okay so
I hope that
clears up your understanding of Max
Delta Min Delta Delta threshold
um so again if you've enjoyed this video
be sure to hit the Subscribe button if
you haven't already
feel free to make some comments below
and I'll see you guys on the next video
take care